that's this is part of the reason that
I'm an admirer of Carl Jung because Jung
makes it very clear that see he was very
interested in the barriers to
enlightenment because if there's if
there's such a thing as being
enlightened let's say then why isn't
everyone enlightened if it's just a
matter of taking the glorious route and
and following your bliss let's say it's
like well that sounds pretty easy why
isn't everyone enlightened and but
Jung's thinking isn't like that at all
you know he he believed that in order to
transform your personality that first of
all you had to be disciplined that's for
sure but you also had to integrate that
part of you that was terrible and
capable of breaking rules and make it
part of you and so then and I really
like that idea well here here's an
example so about 20 years ago I would
say there was a newspaper headline in
one accounted his major newspapers and
it was the Minister of Foreign Affairs
at that time Lloyd Axworthy and he was
talking about what had happened with
Milosevic and in the former Soviet Union
in Yugoslavia and the atrocities that
were being committed and he said that he
that he was caught unawares by that
because he didn't have the imagination
for that kind of evil and I thought well
you know you think that what you're
doing is signaling your virtue by making
a statement like that but from my
perspective all you're doing is stating
your cowardice and your historical
ignorance because if you're gonna be
Minister of Foreign Affairs you bloody
well better have imagination for that
kind of evil because if you don't then
anyone who does wins they beat you and
so you you know and again in the Harry
Potter stories you see he's touched by
evil right he actually has a soul
fragment that's embedded within him
that's as black as anything can possibly
be that's why he could talk to snakes
but without that he wouldn't be able to
have any victory and that's exactly
right psychologically unless you can
think the way that an evil person thinks
then you're defenseless against them
because they'll go places you can't
imagine and then they win and so the
best man I've met it was interesting
even when I was in junior high in high
school because most of my friends
dropped out you know by the time their
grade 10 thereabouts
a lot of them were guys who developed
physically they're pretty powerful and
they're just damn sick and putting up
their hand to go to the bathroom is like
you know they're not doing that anymore
one of my friends got kicked out when he
sort of challenged the gym teacher you
know physically and the gym teacher he
could do an Iron Cross he was a tough
guy and so it was no trivial matter for
my friend to stand up to him but he got
expelled anyways but you know I noticed
that it wasn't it was often the kids
whose character I admired that either
quit or got expelled and they were the
tougher guys who were just sick and
tired of following rules that didn't
take into account their character and
then they go off and work in the oil
rigs or whatever and you could do that
in Alberta at that time that was really
hard work you know so it wasn't like
they were necessarily taking the easy
path but like a harmless man is not a
good man a good man is a very very
dangerous man who has that under
voluntary control and you know you also
see that like one of the central mmm
female stories let's say if the hero
archetype is the central male story
there are variants of hero archetypes
that are relevant to women and one of
them is Beauty and the Beast and you
know Beauty isn't interested in the guy
who isn't the beast she's interested in
the guy who's the Beast and that's
exactly right but she's interested in
the guy who's the beast that can be
civilized and disciplined right and who
can use that in the service well let's
say of a family